[Music]
i love that we get to sleep in
ordering fresh mint mouthwash
extra strength
scarlett johansson and colin jost are
giving fans a rare glimpse into their
life at home
in a new super bowl commercial the snl
star shows his wife their virtual
assistants game day prep hey babe check
this out
alexa
it's game day streaming football on
prime video closing blinds chilling rose
rose well it's an afternoon game
it's like she can read your mind
yep this alexa is a mind reader but then
the smart device starts revealing what
they're secretly thinking about each
other like during their kitchen convos
i'm thinking i should get a spray pan
you know cause it's on wednesday
activating blender funerals on monday
it even reveals colin's thoughts on
scarlet's new play
[Music]
what about the gold papa
can't you see
that treasure all along
it was you
love the eye patch that's
when is the show open march 8th
setting reminder to fake your own death
on march 8th
not uh what's
and the gadget is also there when the
comedian asks about scarlet filming love
scenes
you have to do those love scenes with
hot guys is that fun or is that like the
worst
it's the worst
it's probably better unless it can't
read your mind bad idea and get this it
may just be a scripted parody but the
married couple says this about the super
bowl spot it's from realistic
of our home life
not featured in the glimpse of their
home life scarlet and colin's son cosmo
who they welcomed back in august and it
shouldn't come as a surprise at the time
of his arrival a source told e.t that
the black widow star is incredibly
private and very careful about who she
lets into her inner circle when it comes
to her family and colin agrees the
source adds quote he is 100 on board
with what scarlett wants and keeping
their new baby out of the public eye so
don't expect him to post pics it's hard
to have a lot of complaints she's pretty
awesome but one thing's for sure
scarlett loves motherhood when e.t
caught up with the marvel star in
november she gushed about life with her
daughter rose whom she shares with
ex-husband romaine doriak and her new
baby boy she's seven so she's real she's
very busy uh she's yeah she's kind of
like oh yeah he's cute anyway so all
this happened
non-stop talk and um yeah it's great i'm
you know i feel very fortunate that i've
been able to take this time to really
enjoy you know the early stages of my of
my motherhood uh with our son and it's
it's it's been wonderful i'm in a baby
bliss bubble
[Music]